كلها بتضرب بترفع كذا مره في الشهر
منذ اكثر من عام في الاستعداد للزواج
بشراء الاجهزه الكهربائيه ليفاجئ في كل
مره بزياده الاسعار
علشان اكمل الاجهزه الكهربائيه انا مش
هاقدر اكملها
ان هي وصلت رفعت 25 و30
على الجنيه المصري الذي تم تعويمه لمرتين
في العام الماضي لينخفض للمره الثالثه
الان في البنوك امام الدولار ليفقد الجنيه
المصري اكثر من 60% من قيمته منذ مارس
الماضي الامر الذي ادى للدفاع غير مسبوق
في كافه الاسعار
الجبنه مالها والد الدولار
واعلان رئيس الوزراء محاوله ضبط الاسعار
والزام التجار بوضع اسعار السلع الا ان
مجلس النواب شن هجوما كبيرا على وزير
التموين بسبب لعدم احكام الرقابه وارتفاع
اسعار السلع
يعني رغيف الفول ورغيف الطعميه النهارده
وصل خمسه جنيه سته جنيه لو اسره بسيطه
بتفطر الصبح من الاسر الفقيره عاوزاها 70
80 جنيه عشان تفطر بس فول وطعميه
مقابل الدولار
امام الاستثمارات والسياحه والتصدير
فاضل المصري او السوق المصري هيكون همم
سوق جاذب بشكل كبير للهوتماني وايضا
الصناديق السياديه الخليجيه والعربيه
لدخول لاقتناص الفرص الاستثماريه في بعض
الشركات
السلع كل ذلك يشكل الان اولويه عمل
الحكومه والمواطن على حد سواء في ظل
ارتفاع الاسعار وتوقعاته بزيادات قادمه مع
تخفيض قيمه الجنيه راندا ابو العزم
العربيه القاهره